I didn't just start making vegan foods I
started making vegan foods that are dare
I say bougie I mean they're kind of like
fancy cheese's and like fancy spreadable
meats and you know ratso Chuy's and
casseroles and things cuz a that's what
we are used to eating and B I'm not
interested in just having a square block
of tofu hi I'm Ellen M Cova and today
we're gonna make three vegan cheese's I
experienced this huge transformation
when I started eating clean I would wake
up in the morning and be like boom I'm
digesting fast I feel very energized and
don't get me wrong like I'm human I
cheated along the way and over the years
I discovered that being a break having a
chief doesn't mean like that's it you're
done like you're out of the vegan Club
what it really means is you're on this
journey to eat cleaner eat better if
you're not completely vegan or you don't
want to be completely vegan that's okay
you don't have to be there all the way
you don't have to be a ten you know but
you can be 6.5 you know it's better than
being a three vegan cheeses are gonna
taste similar to regular cheeses they're
not going to be exact replicas if
somebody is going to taste a beak and
cheese and say well this doesn't taste
like milk I'm gonna say you are right so
one of my favorite ways to use the
mozzarella is in the summertime with a
slice of fresh beautiful ripe tomato a
little basil you can drizzle even a
little olive oil on there it also works
really great meltin you can melt it on a
pizza you can stuff it inside a vegan
calzone with some of the cashew ricotta
one of the other reasons that in my
recipe we boil the cashews first it
cooks some of the cashew nuts out and it
kind of assimilates it a little more to
dairy so this cheese is really great to
use in lasagna you could use this and
stuffed shells with any pasta you can
whisk this in and just pump up the
flavor and the creaminess you know I
kind of think people are angry at vegans
because vegans are angry at them but to
shame people for what they're eating I
I think that works there's so many great
awesome things out there that can
replace meat and dairy these days that I
say alright well we're not gonna take it
away
go on own we offer you this other thing
to try try it if it doesn't kill you try
it again
if it doesn't kill you more guess how
many other beings it's not killing we
know now that because of climate change
and because of our depletion of
resources that the amount of meat and
dairy that we are producing now we can
no longer continue to produce at that
rate at that volume to satisfy our
growing population but if that's how
we're trained to eat and that's what we
know about food it's helpful to have
like a transitional food I loved cheese
and we can create creaminess and we can
create a lot of things that we want from
cheese from a sweetness to a melt enos
those things are all happening the point
of the story is if you're reducing your
animal consumption if you're reducing
the impact it has on the environment
you're reducing the impact it has on
your body and you're reducing the impact
it has on all of those animals you can
eat a little bit less meat and a little
bit less dairy and start to feel better
alright
hmm good job
[Music]